[Music]
on today's show we talk about sex and
intimacy and how to practice desire
after we've been married for 10 15 years
we talk about how to raise kids in the
middle of a traumatic situation
we talk about having babies when our
in-laws don't want us to stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what
is happening
this is john with the dr john dolone
show
hey i'm so glad you're here
talking about mental health
relationships wellness all of it
everything
getting right into it today if you want
to be on the show give us a shout triple
eight eight two five that is dave
ramsey's number
so here's the thing america and by
america i mean the 17 of y'all listening
to this i host a couple of different
shows
and this is one of them the one with my
name and face on it
don't know that number one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one but i also host the ramsay show with
dave ramsey a couple of my friends that
one's on the uh on this old thing it's
so rad called the radio it was the best
um and that number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five so if you
wanna call about your mutual funds give
that a shout later on kelly will also
answer that phone
um but if you wanna be on this show call
844 693 3291 god lee this is what i get
for working two jobs james i just need
to have one job it's probably better
that you said that number on this show
than the other way around that would
have been more embarrassing that would
have been weird because if we i'm not
great with the old mutual fund situation
or the baby steps out of debt but here
we are so glad that you're with us james
listen this happened
and you know this happened
because
you texted me about it and kelly uh i
was at an event in florida the other day
i think there's about 750 people at the
event these top business leaders are
from across the country and then i walk
straight off stage and do this 30-minute
live stream to however many bajillions
of other people
who are watching from the
at home on the internets and
the
courtney who's our friend she was
interviewing me and she says
on the live stream in front of everybody
in the club
who are not getting tipsy
she says
um
can you talk about threat threats and
trauma and walk us through like how our
brains respond
to which i said
our brain is always registering threats
in this modern world that we live in it
used to be like oh gosh there's a bear
or a cave or some guy's in a neighboring
community wants to kill us
and then it would respond but now it's
all the time and what i said was we're
always surrounded by
clicks and dings
the challenge is that's not what i said
at all
what i actually said was
on a live stream
with my friend courtney as the host
i've got like
makeup
artists
cameras everywhere
i said
well courtney
i'm surrounded by dicks and clings
dixon clings james
that's what i said
and i
immediately thought i should probably
call out i just said that but i looked
at courtney's face and hit said
carry on
so i just took a dive i made no jokes
i just restated it
no dicks and clings just
clicks and dings
but thankfully we got this show where i
got the wrong stupid phone number all
right let's go to mary in seattle mary
what's up how we doing hey that sounds
way embarrassing so hopefully i don't
fudge it that much on this listen
it was super embarrassing and i'm not
even a guy that gets embarrassed and
even i was like yeah i probably
shouldn't have said it like that i
didn't mean to but it just happened is
what it is what are you going to do
right it just is
hey what's up
okay so
i love listening to your show it's been
a great
way for me to work through some
past issues and stuff but um thank you
so much constantly yeah no it's awesome
i love it um
you're constantly talking about
practicing desire in sexual
relationships and i wanted to know what
you mean by that like what does that
mean exactly ah very cool okay so
practicing desire it's i got the
language from esther perel who i think
is just an extraordinary relationship
expert
um she talks about desire is
transitioning from this this path in
relationships that we find ourselves on
which often is is shrouded in shoulds
and have to's and need to's
versus
what do i actually want to do
and so what happens is you get like
let's say me and my wife we get on a
track which is i need to go do this
thing i
have to do this thing i need to i have
to i have to i should have i should have
done this thing
and then suddenly i never asked myself
the question like what do i actually
want here and so what does that look
like in a relationship so tell me about
your relationship
do you want to practice desire is that
the root of this question
yeah i feel like so my husband and i
have been married 15 years
and i think
i would say we're probably
i don't think we're like in the worst
spot ever sexually
but um
we have been at different times in our
marriage
right now i feel like we're doing okay
but when i hear you talk about like
having just this awesome sex life i feel
like that's what i want i don't know how
to get there i feel like we're kind of
mediocre like
we're not struggling but we're not like
awesome like i want to lean more toward
like hey this is a serious strength in
our marriage where we're just like
totally madly in love i mean we love
each other and
i think we have a great relationship in
general but
just wanting to develop that more to
where it's like
a stronger part of our relationship i
love that thank you for for walking me
through that so
would you be a guinea pig for me on the
show
sure i guess that's why i called right
okay
so you painted a couple of pictures here
and it these often get mushed together
and so i want to make sure that they're
all separate pictures
you said you wanna have you've gotta uh
your sex life is fine your marriage is
fine it's good things are good but you
have this
dream of it being
wheels off right
and then you also mushed into there
we wanna be i want to be madly in love
and
other expectations on top of that so i
want to parse out madly in love
which is a hollywood thing
with
a good marriage
and
a really killer sex life
and there's seasons where i'm madly in
love but man i'm so exhausted and tired
i'm in a crazy work season or we've got
young kids or fill in the blank and so
we're madly in love and madly in love
looks like i gotta help wash the bottles
out and i'm helping with the sheets and
the last thing we're do we're just
wiping poop off ourselves at night when
we go to bed from our kids not not from
us hopefully and we're going to bed and
like madly in love looks like we're
doing what we can to survive and then
other seasons madly in love looks like
wheels are off and um
like man we are clicking on all sexual
cylinders right so
what do you paint me a picture
not a not an overly graphic one like i
painted before the show started what
paint me a picture of
what would it look like
give me a day
of like the dream or what what's your
dream
i think for me like
a lot of times i get into the rut of
like hoods and shoulds and so
for me it would just be like this easy
like yes i totally want you to put the
moves on me i'm loving this instead of
like please just let me go to sleep like
i'm just tired today was a day so so
this is more this is more about your
response to him as opposed to
he's not performing well or he's not the
guy you want him to be right okay no no
i feel like it's probably more me just
feeling like i mean so we have a bunch
of little kids and
there's times where i've felt i don't
feel it as much lately because we've
been talking more openly i mean we've
always talked openly but i think even
more so lately
where i just have felt like okay
all day long i have people hanging on my
legs and wiping snot on me and begging
me for this and that and at the end of
the day i just don't want to be a need
for anyone else
you don't want somebody else coming home
and
hanging all over you and like meeting me
that sounds i don't know it's just like
so we go in these cycles where i'm just
like i just don't want to be needed
right and
and then where i'm like no i love this
like and when i can finally wrap my head
around mentally like actually i do want
this i really enjoy when we are sexually
intimate like
i actually really enjoy it i but getting
to that mental state of like okay yeah
i'm happy with this
there's been a lot of times where i've
just felt like i am so tired why do i
not get to be in control
in charge of when i get to go to sleep
or
like
it's been kind of um
i don't know that's been like years ago
when we had like when i was pregnant and
had little tiny babies it was just like
ah please leave me alone um
and now i feel like we're kind of coming
off of having little babies and
finding ourselves in like the same
holding pattern just because it's been
what it's been for most of our marriage
and i wanna i wanna figure out how to
flip that to where i'm not just like oh
please don't need me i
like i
want to enjoy that more yes okay so i
hear this a lot from especially from
women and i don't want to over gender it
but i hear it a lot from women
i'm not super into it until we
start getting into it
and then i remember oh i really like
this or i heard it said once
um i don't think about sex a lot but
when it starts i really like it and the
more i have it the more i think about it
the more i think about it the more i
want to have it and it kind of it's
self-fulfilling prophecy on one side and
then it rolls off the other side but i
want to push on something you just said
i cannot imagine
like my daughter plays this game called
the sticker game where she grabs your
leg and you have to just walk around the
house and she's attached to your leg
and it's hilarious for like eight
seconds and then it's super not funny at
all and she won't stop
i can't imagine
having little kids all over me all day
long just because they have to eat and
and be carried i can't imagine that and
then can i tell you this one of my
favorite things in the world
um
just totally rat on your husband here um
i work with big tough guys big fancy
ceos people who make a jillion buck like
they they think they're gangsters and
they they are they are
but one of my favorite questions to ask
them is how do you initiate sex at your
house you come home you've been
initiating like boardroom stuff here's
how we're gonna do this on my company
we're gonna do this you sell that and
you're fired and all that then they get
home and they look at their wives and
they're so insecure and they say things
like
so maybe sexy time tonight right they
don't have like a thing like there's no
way like
how does your husband initiate sex
so does it give you like that look and
you're like ugh gross stop like how did
how did how does he get into it
now um
recently we've been trying to schedule
it which i think has actually been good
for me like i was really released to
that idea for a long time and finally i
was like all right we'll try it and i
think it's been good for me to like
kind of alleviate some of the pressure
that i would be like oh is he wanting to
be intimate or can we just go to bed and
like am i going to feel guilty and all
that so that's been like
really great um and you think about it
all day
don't lose that yeah it's true when it's
like we're doing this tonight you can
kind of like do this tonight then you
think about it and then you kind of go
what's that going to be like and then
what kind of sex we're going to have and
then what is right so you start going
down that path anyway which is kind of
awesome but go ahead
yeah so i think that's been really good
but other times if we're just like
cuddling in bed he'll just put his hands
you know like moving his hands on my
body or
um i think we've
we had some times where it was like
i felt like the only time we would ever
be physically intimate at all was like
if we were going to have sex and
that was a few years ago i think we
needed to just hug more and hold hands
more and just kiss just to kiss and
that's been really good too but
sometimes i feel like oh is this loaded
and it like scares me which sounds dumb
i'm not done with my husband but like it
doesn't so here's what's so important
hard to get into no here's what's so
important here's what's so important
so you
you said it so beautifully and i'm gonna
flip it around you and i want you i flip
it around on you and i want you to take
this with you
you said i just don't want to be needed
anymore at the end of a day
so get that
the question i want you to start asking
yourself is what do you need
and how do you need it
and what would you actually want because
you spend all day responding to other
people to your kids i don't know if you
work but to work stuff and then you feel
like you're playing defense against your
husband like what what what like what
are we doing do i have time i'm tired
but can i fit this in what
and all
at the bottom of all that it's being
sacrificed is
what does mary want what does desire
look like for mary
what would it look like for mary to say
hey
tonight is a hug night
i need lots of hugs
tonight is a
sex night but it starts at 8am i need
some help in the kitchen so here's
here's what i want you to have in your
head number one
can sex become and this is where the
practice comes in can sex become a place
that you escape to not escape from
and so at the end of an exhausting day
at the end of a hard work week
can it be a place where
all of the expectations roll off all of
the what you just laid out so perfectly
the i don't know is it gonna be this i
just want to hold the hands can we just
kiss and just go to bed and it uh if i
kiss him then it's gonna turn into this
and then ah now i'm doing it i don't
want to i'm tired
can you get rid of all that stuff and
start being super clear with one another
can you say was that like
at the beginning of the day like when
would you
like how would you actually put that
into practice like i feel like we've
been trying to get more clear when we
decided okay let's start scheduling this
so that is more clear and that has been
super helpful but at the same time my
husband's like well that's lame if it's
like the only time we can ever be
intimate is if we schedule it like can
we never be spontaneous and i'm like i
don't know if i'm there yet i'm trying
and
i want to be there like i want to be
like oh sure it wasn't on the schedule
but you know what i actually desire you
too and so so so you're you're beating
yourself up there you're beating
yourself up because
we're not in a movie
and i want you to free yourself from
that
the simple solution to that to what you
the question you just asked me is you go
ahead and put an extra one or an extra
two on your calendar for the week and
you surprise him
and that way you both win it's on your
calendar you know it's coming you can
plan for it all day
and he doesn't know it's coming
and you can say what would it look like
for me
to totally
get after him
and then you start to feel what would
that power feel like what about him
meeting my needs for once
what does that look like and i'm going
to wear what i want to wear and do this
how i want to do this where i want to do
this
and i'm going to stick to kids in front
of a stupid tv screen because i don't
even care does that make sense
it's about you moving to offense and so
that that sim that thing you just said
is simply about i'm not at a place where
i just think about it at four o'clock in
the afternoon he walks in the door but
i'm gonna already have it on my calendar
or i'm gonna text him and i'm gonna have
him
meet me in the garage i don't know
whatever works for you guys man right um
i want you to focus on not what is but
what could be and you begin to practice
how do i get myself there
and it may be that you've got two let's
say y'all put two on on
uh on the calendar each week two days
we're gonna sleep together two days this
week
and you go ahead and put two other ones
just for you you don't tell them about
them and one's in the morning and one's
like on the afternoon sometime or in the
evening whatever
one is hey i'm in the mill cooking
dinner can you come help me in the
bedroom real quick and then all of a
sudden he's like what is happening and
it's gamer
my hunch is
you thinking about that planning that
we'll get that thing to get the train
going down the track for you
and if it doesn't he doesn't know
so you haven't you haven't let him down
that's one of your special stars if that
makes sense
right the second thing i want you all to
do is i want you to get emily nagotsky's
book come as you are i'll link to it in
the show notes it's the single best book
on sex i've ever read in my life it's
written for women
um about their bodies and they were just
left out of the conversation most of
them were
it's a it's a phenomenal book but it's
also really important for men to read
too
and it talks this whole idea about a sex
drive is nonsense it's a it's a series
of
breaks and gas pedals and it just hear
me say this it's about how do i turn
more of the ons on and more of the offs
off
and those things happen 24 hours a day
is 365. they're not about the 45 minutes
we've put on our calendar for for having
sex or for not having sex
it's about how do i create a world
that my wife feels
free and has space to let her mind go
bananas with me as the at the end of
that fantasy
how do i create a world where my husband
feels connected and safe and loved here
at home or whatever words he needs
to where he is ready to party when the
time comes
and so it's about creating an entire new
ecosystem around a married couple
especially folks who've been married for
a while
and here's the last thing i want to pass
along to you
you guys are going to reinvent things
now
and so what we often try to do and you
may have heard me say this we often try
to drag our past remember we were dating
and it just was like this
and then it's like remember we were just
newlyweds and we had no kids we were
having sex at four in the afternoon on a
wednesday on the kitchen table like
where are those days
and what i'll tell you is
we take those days and we compare them
to what we have now and we say oh we're
lacking something we used to have
passion and now we're just old and
boring or we used to be
reckless and rambunctious and now
blah has got to pay the light bill and
let's just watch the office and go to
sleep and so what i want to tell you is
you can't compare you're now to then
different worlds different people
different experiences you got kids
everywhere you got expectations you all
look different everything's different
and
you get to create what
next looks like
and for some people after year 15 that's
when they they're like hey we're gonna
start
doing dress-up week or we're gonna start
what's your craziest fantasies here's a
fun one here's an envelope system it's
called the john doloni erotic envelope
system it's not for sale it's for free
they're
10 envelopes
out of deck of drawer you have at your
house
you take five and he takes five
you each write down one crazy thing you
want to try or it may be boring i want
boring married person sex or i just want
a french kiss for 45 minutes and that's
it hands behind your back sucker or
maybe it's fill in the blank whatever it
is
and
once a month once a week you commit
to we're going to draw a random envelope
and no matter what we're doing what's in
that envelope or i'll i don't i may not
fully understand what you're asking here
or how this is even physically possible
but i will give it my the best shot
right whatever it is
and
it adds some mystery all day you're like
wonder what's in that stupid envelope
and he's gonna be like oh i hope she
picks this one envelope and you're gonna
be like oh gosh i hope he just picks
this envelope and you're gonna get there
and you're both gonna be into it and
it's gonna be awkward and you're gonna
be laughing and it's gonna be weird and
you know what you're gonna feel like
newlyweds again
you're gonna feel like you're dating
again it's gonna feel weird and a little
bit ah what are you doing
and that's gonna be how you reclaim and
practice intimacy and you may not even
be able to get through them it may be a
disaster and you'll laugh and just go
back to married old boring person like
boring old person married sex right
but little things like that that you get
to recreate what this thing looks like
and so what i wanted you to hear me say
is the trapped feeling you have is a
thousand percent valid and real
and it's a thousand percent in your head
and it's a thousand percent something
you can correct for
and
let me leave you with this last thing i
said i only had one more thing one thing
commit to each other to being curious
not judgmental
be curious
when you find one of that random tuesday
at two in the afternoon and you think if
my husband was here i would rip every
shred of clothing has off his body in
the yard i don't even care be curious
about that moment what about that moment
that day
what about him what about you what is
going on that might be something you can
build into your life
on days he comes home and he's like hey
is it time for sexy time and you're like
ah how about i stab you in the face with
like a fork i'm holding in my hand
take inventory of that don't judge
yourself don't beat yourself up don't
beat him up ask yourself be curious
why do i feel like i want to stop this
guy that i love in the eyeball and i
like sleeping with him like it's not
normal why do i feel like that be
curious about it and then you can begin
to reverse engineer the world that you
actually want versus the one that you're
experiencing does that make sense
yeah i know i think that sounds great i
feel like just listening to you and
giving it's like giving me hope that
like hey we can do better we can get
past the fact that we've had all these
babies and like been tired for a lot of
years and it's like we can do something
different and i want to so i'm glad for
your advice thank you yes so get that
book we'll link to it in the show notes
read it together
and there's gonna be parts where you're
like whoa and there's the other parts
you're like i don't really get that read
it together don't agree with all of it
that's great but it's going to give you
all something to work towards and then
go with the john delaney erotic envelope
system it's free and it's amazing and it
will change everything merry
man
you make me happy for mankind and
womankind you're awesome we'll be right
back on the dr john dolani show
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot
right or if in the morning your back
hurts if you have any of these issues
you may need to check out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dream cloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer ever 400 bucks in
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for delony listeners
that's a total of about 650 in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code d-e-l-o
good night
all right we are back jack let's go to
john in second oh what's up john
hey um
hi what's up dude sorry i kind of bombed
you there you doing all right
you're fine yeah um so i have we have a
son who was born um just over three
weeks ago
and he was born at 33 weeks so he's
still in the nicu yeah how's everybody
how's he doing
uh he's doing great he is above where
they thought he would be uh weight wise
and he's really coming around to
learning how to feed so we're very cool
hey congratulations man that's awesome
thank you thank you um on top of that we
also have a six-year-old daughter of
course you do because why not right why
not
awesome right and so we are really
struggling with how to balance our time
and focus and attention and you know be
the best parents we can be for both of
them
excellent
so
is one of y'all staying
in i always call it nike and i know it's
nicu
is one of y'all staying there 24 7.
how's that working right now
well um so what we do typically is my
life goes during the day while our
daughter's in school okay and then
after i get out of work um i will go
home for dinner most of the time and
then we will both together go up um
you know shortly after my daughter's
bedtime
and we'll both go up and see him that
way excellent has your daughter been
able to go visit
no so they're not letting children in
hospitals right now um we've facetimed
and we show our pictures almost every
day
ah that makes me bonkers yeah okay
um yeah that would be an important
milestone and
that would be really helpful but it's
not happening so can't control it so i'm
gonna move on to things i can't control
so man number one
i'm so grateful that your baby is coming
along and do they have a projected come
home date
uh not yet they told us to expect our
due date which is right around
thanksgiving oh very cool man so what a
thanksgiving what a holiday season and
hopefully it snows where you are of
course it will and then y'all can just
have some time just to
breathe you'll probably haven't taken a
deep breath in a long time
no it's been a long two years yes yes
yes
so here's um i'm gonna give you a couple
number one
your six-year-old is lucky to have you
this new baby's lucky to have you and
your wife
and
good for you guys good for you guys
i'm gonna give you a couple of pieces of
advice that a
a one of them is a what a
former professor gave to me and it
worked magic in my home
and then talk a little bit about grief
and walking through what this will look
like for your kid okay
so
um i had hank my son i think he was five
or six when josephine was coming along
and my professor
she
gave me one sentence to tell to my son
while my daughter was in utero
and that was to always refer to the baby
as his baby
as his sister
and she said that children she's super
right children crave ownership
and they crave participation they crave
purpose actually we all do as grown-ups
but it kind of gets sucked out of us as
we just
get dead-eyed jobs and we just clock in
and out for the rest of our lives
so i would love for you to start
referring to this little boy as
her baby when you talk about it
or
her
brother
and what an important role she's gonna
play
and
how she's going to read books and i want
you to color pictures and i want you to
you say it out loud and all write down
the letter she's probably working on her
letters right now
she can dictate a letter that you can
take to the baby and maybe video you
reading it to the baby
but i want her to start getting some
ownership of this
and here's where that's important
she's not going to be able to go to the
hospital and visit but she's going to be
incredibly invested in this little boy
she's going to be invested in her role
as a big sister and as a not as a
caretaker but as a participant in the
life of the blood of this family
that's really important so just saying
things like
you want to see some pictures of your
baby you want to see some pictures of
your brother you want to see some
pictures of let's write baby let's draw
baby a picture and you sit down and
color with her
and you color a book and
uh she can call her a book and y'all
take the pictures and just take a
picture of the baby in the nicu with her
pictures next to it does that make sense
yeah absolutely okay so we're going for
ownership and participation there
the second thing
and this is such a gift you can give
your child
is to teach her
first hand
about fear
about grief
about sadness
about if you're a people of faith about
what prayer looks like in real time
and so what that will look like is you
saying things like
daddy's really
been scared that little brother
um was so sick
and little brother decided to come into
the world really early and so the
doctors and hospital people have really
been taking good care
but that makes daddy scared
because daddy wants you you two to be
safe daddy wants you to to be healthy
and right now daddy's scared
and so what your daughter gets a
ringside seat is to see her dad be a
human be vulnerable be real and to still
be breathing
and eating
and holding her hand while you say these
things
and you and i brother we were trained
to hide those kind of things from little
people from little kids to hide those
things from our spouses to hide those
things from our workplaces and just be
robots and what it does is when your
daughter feels scared or sad it makes
her feel crazy
because nobody in her world
ever
models what that looks like
and so you have an opportunity in a real
life situation your wife does too but
she's not here so i'm talking to you
to model what being honest and open
looks like i'm really scared you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to say a
prayer
i'm really scared right now so i'm going
to write little baby a
uh
a note do you wanna write a note with me
do you see where i'm going with that
yeah
and here's the final thing
that i'll i mean there's a million
things we could talk about man i'd love
just to hug you dude i know
those are long long nights and they add
up to long long weeks and long long
months and
one of the great curses of our time
brother is that we have made
our children
the circle i mean the center of our
homes
and they were not designed to carry the
weight of our homes
and so what i want to free you from
is
there's gonna be a couple of months a
couple of more weeks
when your daughter's just gonna have to
deal because you're gonna go be at the
hospital with her little brother
and you're gonna feel like you're
abandoning her you're not
you're gonna your wife is gonna feel
like well what about her what about her
you've got an emergency on your hand and
y'all are doing the right thing
and what your daughter's gonna realize
is over time now she's six and so she's
gonna
say what about me because she's six
that's what six-year-olds do right but
over time
she's gonna realize
whoa my parents love runs deep
and they will sleep at hospitals
they will stay up late they will get up
early they will spend all day
with me
with each other with brother
when crap hits the fan that's the kind
of parents my parents are
and so your daughter is not designed to
carry the weight of that family she
needs to know early on
she's learning right now man there's an
emergency mom and dad
they run in and sometimes that means i'm
left outside for a bit with grandparents
or with friends or whoever
and it's gonna feel like she's missing
out but it's also gonna be a gift to her
that the whole family doesn't revolve
around her
i want you and your wife to be at peace
y'all are doing a good job my brother
thank you
can you be honest with me is this a
scary time are you starting to be able
to breathe a little bit
a little bit yeah um to be honest one of
the biggest things we're running into
now is that like our daughter is
starting to act out more yeah
and so like it's
we're running into you know okay how do
we
like how do we stop
like how do we help her through
like the fits and things that are
happening how do we kind of let her know
like hey
it's not okay to freak out and hit your
parents but at the same time like i
i can't imagine life like what she's
going through at her age as well you
know what i mean absolutely and and yeah
she's six and so her body is just
screaming for connection and you guys
have been busy and when you're our home
you're probably not present there's
probably one foot in the hospital at all
times
and which is normal or one foot staring
at a computer screen trying to figure
out the bills and the medical stuff they
just all that so yeah you got a little
kid screaming for a connection that's
where
i hate to say you can double dip but
when you sit down with coloring books
and you bring it to her and say let's
color a picture together
let's that you're talking 20 minutes of
focus time
and her whole body goes
or getting you may have heard me talk
about this getting a go to michael's or
go to um hobby lobby or something and
get a small little canvas
and on that canvas get some paints
and write down here's our family values
here's our family values we love each
other even when it's hard
we treat each other with respect
we say thank you we say i love you we do
those kind of things and then when she
throws a fit
you point back to that and say oh my
goodness
i'm so sad that
i'm so sorry that you opted out
because we don't throw fits because
remember this is who we are
so you've chosen to step away for a few
minutes
and
man as soon as you're ready to to treat
each other with dignity respect we don't
hit in this family we all wrote it down
here together and bring her into this
conversation but let her know and then
when you're gone you can point to it
when you're heading to the hospital you
can say
remember we care for one another in the
good days and the bad days this is where
we're headed off to and she'll go yeah
because that's who we are that's who we
are but yes
meeting those connection things upstream
that you going to her hey let's make a
video in a movie hey let's let me and
you let's it's it's saturday morning
we're going to go to have breakfast date
just me and you and let's get dressed up
you can put a button-on shirt up shirt
and tuck it in tuck your shirt in and
she can put on some fancy clothes and
you take her to cracker bale or do
something like that and spend that time
it may be an hour it may be 30 minutes
it may be an hour and a half a couple of
times a week that may be all you can
squeeze into
man those focused moments are so so
important and yes you're right there's a
balance when she does throw a temper
attention when she does start you know
things start rattling man that's part of
it some of that's just hard hard season
right now
um
yeah it's really challenging but also
remember
also remember yeah that six-year-old
little body is just saying
i need to be connected i need to be
connected and be connected so she can't
hit
but there's a context for that thank you
so so much my brother
y'all are good folks we'll be right back
on the dr john delaney show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
what up we are back let's go to kathy in
austin hey kathy what you doing
hi how are you
i am outstanding and how about you
better than i deserve oh well played i
like what you did there so what's up how
can i help
hi so um i'm 28 years old and my husband
and i we just got married last year
both of us we have our college degrees
and we actually both became debt-free a
month before our wedding very cool
you're very proud about that you should
be congratulations what's your degree in
uh my degree is in finance and his is in
business excellent excellent very cool
so how can i help
yes um so we have our own
uh plan we would love to
travel for a bit we want to do a couple
of things just the two of us so travel
you know buy a house buy a new car and
then eventually we live up to have
children down the line
um how what's been kind of been a speed
bump um with my family in particular um
this is
this is really hard i've never really
said this out loud to so many people
um both of us
actually were diagnosed with high
functioning autism
aka asperger's when we were both very
young kids
and
my parents have it in their heads that
because of that
i am not capable of being a mother
and i want to know
i would like to know
how
boundaries can be set with that and i
also worry
of how my parents it should
reggie and i choose to have
children
how they are going to treat my kids and
how they're going to question my
parenting skills yeah
just the way you said that
hit me right in my guts
and i can't wrap my head around what it
would be like
what it would feel like
not to think but what it would feel like
in my body
if my mom was to say i don't think
you'll be a good mom
i don't think you'll be a good father
it's been hurting me for a while yeah
well yeah
that hurt is legit man and i'm sorry
that someone looked you in the eye and
said that that's hard
um so
you say high functioning you guys are
kicking butt doing great tell me tell me
articulate for the listener and for me
what what does that
look like on a day-to-day basis what are
some
things that you feel like
are different from you
for you and your husband than
is for a neurotypical person
well at this point in our adult life
i think the only thing that i think a
normal person you know might see is that
maybe don't say normal you're normal
you're just like us
yeah yeah because everybody's got
something right everybody's got a bunch
of somethings
right
well i guess it's
maybe we tend to be on the shy side just
because we want to show a good face when
we meet new people and
just sometimes we have you know quirky
personalities and i think
in my life every other person
has something quirky about them but
otherwise nowadays should anybody
find out whether i tell them or not they
just
didn't know that either one of us was on
the spectrum gotcha and so your mom
is my mom and my dad does she say that
does your mom and dad say that you would
not be a good mom
because of your diagnosis or because
there are things that you
present to the world that concerns them
well
i'm the oldest of four children okay um
all of my siblings are grown up now
and
my dad at one point has said
to me that he has asked each of his kids
you know just as a grown-up when you
start to get into a relationship
or whether you're in a relationship or
not just look at your life and see
what things could be like whether you
have children or whether you decide to
not have children okay and just to look
at it evenly like same time frame
in which you know at one point before i
met my husband i did consider that
because i didn't think
you know
any man was going to love me for who i
was just because i felt
that my diagnosis was going to hold me
back or if somebody was not going to be
able to handle it and at some point i
actually just stopped telling people
because
they're either going to love you for who
you are or
when they find out they're either going
to
take advantage of it or they're not
going to know what to do and run away so
i just at one point just stop telling
people
that
putting that aside
for you i realized with parenting i'm
not a parent yet and i understand that
you're not supposed to just see
parenting as rainbows and butterflies
and seeing it through rose-colored
glasses i i realized that
so
is there something is there something
that
are you unable to and i'm gonna ask some
probing questions okay these aren't
accusations these are just facts
are you unable to
connect with somebody else
no
you you are able to connect
absolutely do you feel your feelings
i do
are you able to interact with somebody
else when they're hurting are you able
to lean into that
yes i can
and same as my husband yeah
so i i think there's a lot of
preconceived notions from people
absolutely
don't understand
well that's what i'm asking
is this is your mom does she sensing
that stuff i i just can't imagine why
she would say that
and so let me let me get to these let me
get to this because we could spend all
day on this and i don't want to speak
ill of your mom that would be ugly of me
right so
most important be honest
about your connections kids need radical
connection i want to always go back to
that word that's the most important
thing
just from my conversation with you again
you and i've never hung out i don't know
you and your husband
i mean i i
you just sound like a wonderful
extraordinary human being
and
i assure you i've got
if you line up the quirk
the quarko meter i probably got you beat
10x okay
i'm a weird person
so they tell me
um
so
if you can provide radical connection
and if you can if you can
demonstrate and model love and you can
make sure people are fed including
yourselves and take care of and all
those things it sounds like you're doing
i don't see an issue at all
what i would suggest is
walking having people walk alongside you
and so
you got that
yes i have my
wonderful wonderful aunt who's also my
godmother she's like a second mother to
me awesome and my grandparents as well
and
with that i know that
you know being on the spectrum it might
be a little bit more difficult but
i've been babysitting since i was 13
years old and i took upon myself to do
some part-time babysitting since the
summer
and i've always been cpr and first aid
certified and i just enjoy being around
children that's awesome
and so so
to answer your your boundaries question
this isn't just an autism not autism
thing
um
but let me back up when i said have
someone to walk along the side with you
obviously having a great family member a
good like some family connection some
good friend connections is great i would
love you and your husband to sit down
with a marriage counselor not because
there's anything wrong
but right to
walk alongside as a neutral third party
and i've done this for couples
where you ask the questions what is the
picture of
a saturday morning with an eight month
old what does that look like
right whenever one of us gets overloaded
and we need to disconnect or unplug
what does that look like because you
can't always do that with a baby
right what does
what does taking a step back and
communicating well what needs are right
it's asking all those questions and
begin to map some of those things out
the challenge that
like being around children is awesome
babysitting is awesome
the difference there is kids never go
home
and so there's something about i can
plug in and babysit for a couple of
hours all day and go all in and then i
can go home and just stare off into
space
sure when you've got babies they're just
still sitting there screaming about
something and pooping on everything and
so they don't ever go home
and so being able to map those out with
somebody just a neutral third party i
think would be so valuable and it will
give you and your husband
some
some
clear expectations that y'all can write
down and you can point back to and say
this is who we are is who we said i'm
having one of my saturday mornings where
i need to dis disconnect and unplug for
a bit i need you to step into this gap
or we've got somebody on call we've got
ant on call whatever that looks like for
us
but backing up even further again this
is not an autism question this is just a
parent's boundary question
unfortunately
you can't make your parents accept you
you can't make your parents love your
their grandbaby
i think they will
it's not a matter of loving my child
it's the fact that one they will always
be fearful of my child's faith being
concerned 24 7
because they
they have that little faith
in us taking care of a child long term
and b
my mom has it in her head that a social
worker has to be assigned to us
specifically so here's here's what i
want you to do the research
and that's not the case yeah i want you
to actually reach out to a social worker
you and your husband actually oh you did
okay and then did they walk you through
like they did okay they said regardless
if somebody is on the spectrum adhd
bipolar whatever it is
the most they could honestly do is just
go to the parents house make sure it's
safe make sure the baby's happy and
safe
and anybody who's tried to put a false
claim
that we're about parents we can file a
harassment case against that person yes
so here's what i want you to do
there's somebody who knows you well
and she may be misguided she may have
her own challenges she may be struggling
throwing stuff but there's somebody who
knows you well being your mom somebody
who knows you all being your dad and
they have done an unimaginable thing in
my mind and they've stared at their
child and said you are not qualified or
good enough to be a parent
that's a huge accusation
and
my first response is we'll screw you
then
but
i also
always want to
get some data
so i would if i'm you i would go talk to
a professional
i would get my husband and we would go
sit with a marriage counselor and we
would say we want to have kids
and my parents
think that's a terrible idea they want
us out of this deal
and we think we are ready for this
and that counselor can walk you all
through together
and if ultimately in their in y'all's
opinion in the professional's opinion
dude we are going to be great parents
every parent's got their challenges we
know how we're going to work together to
overcome these things we're going to
have the right support around us
that's when you go to your mom and dad
and say
this is happening
you all can choose to opt in
and love us and support us and love this
grandbaby or you all can opt out that's
y'all's grown-up decision that y'all can
make on your own i'm not gonna make it
for you
we hope you'll join us
but you're not going to
um
second-guess everything that we do
you're not going to monday morning
morning quarterback our lives and by the
way this happens for people who aren't
autistic too
over-involved in-laws
and it may be that they are just they
think they are doing the best thing for
this baby and for y'all
ugh what a mess
i can't tell you whether having a child
is a great idea for you to because i
don't know y'all
and there's something bizarre about
either your mom has got some major
issues
or there is a glaring
blind spot in y'all's world that you're
not seeing
and so i want to get you to get a second
opinion with a professional's gonna look
you guys in the eye walk alongside you
for a season
and say man we are ready to rock and
roll it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great
or
in my professional opinion i don't think
this is a wonderful idea
and then y'all can have some peace and
then you get to start drawing boundaries
you get to start drawing boundaries and
like your social worker said people are
making false claims against you yeah you
report that nonsense
hopefully your mother and dad will see
the writing on the wall this is gonna
happen
and we're gonna need you we're gonna
want you in the life of our baby in our
lives and we hope you'll walk alongside
us and be our biggest cheerleaders but
if you're gonna throw grenades by
felicia
life's too short
thank you so much for that call kathy
reach out to somebody and man best of
luck to you
i love love love your heart all right as
we wrap up today's show
man frank turner's got a new record
coming out in february and he released
his new single just a few months ago now
and it's so good it's off his upcoming
frank turner hardcore album and he's an
acoustic artist and i love the fact that
he's anyway insider baseball but
the song is called haven't been doing so
well and it goes like this
it's a day with a y in it so obviously
i'm over it and i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired i've tried not to
worry and i've tried being sorry for
being born in the wrong place at the
wrong time because i've been messed up
stressed out talking to myself again
locked up left out terrified of
everything wound up found out waiting
round for something to give
don't you ever wake up and suspect that
you were simply never cut out to be the
kind of person they'd expect the kind of
person you intended to be and i keep it
all in with my idiot grin and i'm doing
my best but there's very little left so
cut me some slack if i crawl back into
my shell
i haven't been doing so well
frank none of us have been doing so well
but we're getting better every day right
here on the dr john elon's show